allons with us in atlanta hey Alan tell
me your story what's your net worth hi
Dave it's great to speak with you thanks
so much what you do thank you then that
works I guess my pocket compared to
those last year I'm just a 1.2 million
now I'm not 60 years old okay and what's
it invested in well 800,000 retirement
accounts roughly 200,000 and liquid
assets and then the balance of it is in
my house cars etc there's no good all
right very cool very cool and what was
your average income through your working
lifetime sir it vary greatly during most
of that time I was 100% Commission
salesman and so it if I had to average
it out it probably between 80 and 90
okay did you inherit did you guys
inherent money now no money inherited
okay all right so what do you attribute
the fact that you're a millionaire in
America where people say that can't be
done now well it's it was pretty simple
for us really we we just never changed
our lifestyle to any great degree
because I was 100% commissioned you
never knew you know you're only as good
as your last sale so you always try to
keep a good rainy day fund well the
rainy day fund just kept growing and
growing and growing rainy day fortunate
because God has been very very good to
us
and we give him the glory the rainy days
have had been few and far between so we
just met it would put the money away
very cool how much debt do you have now
and how much debt have you been in
through the years zero I'm a bit now we
pay the house off over ten years ago and
I just I could never tolerate that even
before it was it was cool I just I just
couldn't take that I couldn't I couldn't
reconcile in my mind increasing my
lifestyle through debt I it just
bothered me to the point where now I
don't care
everything is everything's paid for and
that's the way I like it how many new
cars of y'all bought in your life well
we keep our cars for ten years so we
general will buy a Newland
we pluck three two cars in the truck
okay
in the trucks for work it's it's 2008
it's got 130,000 miles on it still
nothing like the day I bought it so I'll
keep it for quite a while
what part in your financial plan does
generosity play well we tied of course
and we've gotten to the point now where
we can we can help out our family
members when they need it
and it's such a blessing to be able to
do that to be a resource for people when
they truly made it my mom I have issues
with my mother she says she's in poor
health and I'm able to help out and it
never is a burden for us so we praise
God were able to do that what's the most
ridiculous expensive thing you all have
bought most ridiculous expensive thing I
guess it has to be one of the cars I
mean we bought a top-end car and we
probably could have saved a little money
by buying a little model but it was just
a Honda Accord top car yeah we never we
never spent a lot of money we just my
wife is very frugal I had to give her a
lot of the credit because she'll come
home we've been married for 37 years
she'll come home proudly from the
grocery store every time and tell me how
much she saved with coupons she's a
coupon clipper from way back and she
never paid full price for anything so
what'd you pay for your last pair of
blue jeans well it was in high schools
you don't wear blue jeans at all yeah I
wear blue jeans but is my wife okay
what's your wife's pay for your last
pair of blue jeans I'll probably ten
bucks
the ones you're wearing like today well
you know khakis today the ones that go
today probably twenty dollars okay all
right what is your recommendation to a
25 year old listening to you right now
don't change your standard of living
when you get a raise put the money away
don't bite on the on the commercials and
say you need to you need this you need
that to be happy because it's just not
true what do you say to people that say
oh I need to live today if to heck with
tomorrow
I don't want to be 60 years old for them
and joined this well tomorrow we'll get
here and when it does it's going to hurt
so you got to be satisfied with the
small things it's like God tells us in
Hebrews 13:5 keep yourself free from the
love of money and be satisfied with what
you have very cool now contentment is a
key thing in people that build wealth
I've noticed that over the years and
it's it shows up often in these hours
Alan you're a great American success
story you and your wife God has blessed
you sir and he's blessed the the
diligence that you put into this and I
appreciate you sharing your story thank
you god bless you